hide afternoon I'm pollyana this is
Leonardo
we are instructional structural
engineers we are from Brazil and we
bring to you today our research about
image processing for continuous
monitoring of cracks in civil
constructions I know that you all are
anxious to see the code but first I'll
talk about a little of engineering so
you can see the importance of the
importance of this method just crack
crack is not just something ugly in the
wall like you see the the cracker also
could be the way the the structures show
us that something goes wrong and is very
important to monitoring to see if there
is something they could be a danger to
the the cracks might be caused by
plastic deformation time or expansion or
chemical reactions and the the weed of
craig's is an important parameter the we
used to class them and now the danger
that it represents you to all structure
he we can see a little spoiler of our
our research so the first type to
protect this structure is then 5a the
frac oh my god is intensified the crack
after we monitoring we monitor the
development to know if establish or not
I guess everyone here has things I would
like this this is the visual inspection
but the idea okay issuing and file our
crack is when is a small crack that we
can not see with the naked eye so we use
the microscope or some equipments that
use waves to identify small discontinued
its own structure and we can identify a
crack before the appears today the main
equipment that we use to monitoring the
crack is Telltale's it is this equipment
here and we can measure the width of the
crack over the time to see if a thin
crack is becoming a white crack and it's
possible to know how faster it is
happens and now I I will talk about the
applications because around the wall we
have many examples of disasters we could
we could being have been avoided we have
the monitoring of the cracks he is an
example in my country Brazil I I don't
know if he you if you know about it it
was the biggest environmental disaster
in our country then broke in 2015
here is more pictures of this disaster
and he it's new that says engineer says
he warned it Samarco it's the owner of
this damn about cracking in front of
them so before the disasters happen
engineer warned that there is sound
cracks and nothing was done and now we
we know what happened
this is an example near to you in
Florida bridge fell after they found
Craig's and often was don't you hear
some more pictures and this is this
disaster what happened
mmm and here we have another example it
is to show you that this method is going
beyond the civil see structural engineer
this airplane disintegrated in the air
and the cracks also were were found
before just a minute this is not the
plane that of disaster but this is the
the new that says airplane that is
integrated with parachutes in Allen
tation presented the trick shion's and
cracks so this is a little of the
importance of our method and now we will
show you thank you for
for your introduction our research is in
the initial phase we are very excited
about it because it has many
applications mainly to to make
structures more safer than they are
today
in our country have also another
collapse of a dam that killed more than
200 people so this could be avoided if
the monitoring of these structures were
effectively done so the method is quite
simple but the results are very
important so I'm going to show you how
we did it so first we have some
functions to do the the text to put the
text on the pictures that we we are
gonna monitoring of the structures and
then we have some calculations first I'm
going to show you the raw video for to
monitoring the cracks we need to take a
big pictures a lot of pictures of that
or make a movie make a video and this
video it can be taken for any any period
of time you can take it for one day one
week one month or years so you go
processing this information you can
monitoring the crack in real time so I'm
gonna show you the raw video it's taken
from microscope so in this case it's
about sick
100 times okay bigger so let's see the
the crack movie so it starts to expand
so it's a traction crack we see here the
the monitoring with a caliper so the
crack is open this is just a monitoring
for 30 seconds but it could be any time
so this is the raw video so we are gonna
import this video to the mathematica and
we can also couple other sensors than
the image we can use temperature
moisture forces that are going at the
same time so we install sensors and we
read the data and get all together so we
can do this analysis by a couple way so
we get the video we split the video in
frames so you can input pictures or you
can input the video so we get the frames
in this case we have 3 6 5 frames
temperature just for example it's this
curve and we get the frames of the video
so here we have the first frame and here
their last frame and now we have to
decide which points which base points we
are going to take for reference
first we try to use some target target
for this to establish the points just
like we saw in the first slide like here
we draw some points we were worried that
math America couldn't track the point so
we did these but it was not necessary
this function this track function this
work it very well so we just pick it
this point
can you see very small and this point
one of each side of the crack so we
establish the coordinates of these
points right here we choose and we use
the image feature track to track the
position of these points in each frame
so for its each frame it's going to
calculate the position of the frame it's
calculating now it's running and then we
have to establish the factor that
converts pixels to millimeters so we
have a template the microscope has a
template that we can easily convert
these the pixels the dimensions of the
pixels in millimeters
it's tehrani this is a very good
opportunity to use parallel computing
because they are independent the
analysis of each frame is is independent
so we could use a cluster for large
amount of data so mathematic can do it
very well so here we have the
coordinates of the points let's show
some more here
the coordinates of this point and this
point for each frame then we are gonna
calculate the distance between these
points and we are gonna overlay the
numbers the dimensions and the data the
information on each frame so it's gonna
be it's very fast then we can export the
video and then we can show the result of
this so here we have the video
and we have the information about the
the distance so in the first frame we
have zero distance between the points so
the crack is is at the initial state and
we can go through the frames so we can
see that the value measured by math
America is the same than the caliper we
did this enough in still frame that
holds a piece of concrete so we can
adjust the width of the crack and we
measured it with this digital caliper
and the results were very good so here
we have the the measured crack this is a
traction so it's opening and we have the
measures let me show you the video we
can export each frame and make a video
here we have the horizontal displacement
the vertical displacement and the
distance between them
we can also add here the temperature or
any parameter that is measured at the
same time of the video and one advantage
of this method is that you can see the
crack you can see the crack opening you
can see the crack closing so it's a it's
an advantage in relation to the usual
methods that only use a sensor that only
gives you numbers so if you have a peek
if you have a strange value you can go
to that frame and see what happened
maybe earthquake that shake the the
microscope or shaken the structure so
you can see what happened you can see if
there were if there was war going inside
the crack or something around the the
crack so but we have challenges because
when the when we do this by image we
have a 2d system so if the crack do does
this traction or compression it's okay
but if the crack bends like this or if
the crack moves in the first cow like
this or like this how are we gonna take
these measures so the maybe there are
some some solution for that we could
take the some the size of the base
points so if the cracks go in this the
point the diameter of the point may
decrease so there are some some
solutions for that that we may implement
in this in this code but this is only a
part of the work we intend to use AI to
recognize not only monitoring the cracks
but recognize the which of the crack and
to know what kind of crack is that and
if the crack is a thread to the
structure if it's going to cause a
collapse or it's going to cause some
problem so we we will implement this and
[Music]
we have some some ways to do that so
here we have examples so we can find
Poor's holes in the in the concrete we
can find cracks and we can also measure
the which of the cracks so the goal here
is true use automated system to
monitoring all the cracks of a large
structure a large them so we are gone we
are designing a robot so it will have a
camera a high-resolution camera these
GPS a positioning system and it's going
to take one picture at each millimeter
and it's going to do the diagonals for
the crack so we can let the robot go
through the structure climbing also
climbing vertical wall and collect all
the information send to the base to the
base and this is processing in real-time
so after that we can have a map of all
the cracks on the structure and
engineers can take decisions about what
should be done about that so that's it
our project
it's just starting we are looking for
financial support for that because we
have a lot to do the rowboat and some de
Klerk we need also the cluster so if
you're interested you can talk to us
thank you very much for your attention
and hope you enjoyed it
I guess we have some time for questions
we are going to work on that because we
want to in this case it's a microscope
picture but we can also use usual camera
that's going to make pictures of the
area so it's we are going to know what's
happening around the crack so this is
also a very good information in the
future
yeah we don't have this record yeah we
have many problems in public
constructions yeah corruption and many
problems old structures that they don't
have maintenance so this is a problem
but when you monitoring cracks you have
time to take measurements for for the
strengthening of the structure or to
avoid yeah take samples of the structure
is one part of the diagnosis you can
take samples and also do the monitoring
of the structure and this method we can
apply not just in concrete structures we
can also apply in ships vessels and also
in airplane structures yeah you have
yeah no it's it's it's for the
maintenance of the off the dam yeah it's
not an alarm yeah yeah it's it's very a
very earlier advise okay
no not yet but we have an another
project yeah we saw a many interesting
papers here that use some tools above
with sounds that can be used like this
we have an example for we have another
project that it should do inspections in
facade of buildings so that there is a
robot it has a hammer it goes like this
and by the sound it knows if there is a
problem there analyzing the sound but
this this project it's it's just here in
in in idea okay thank you very much
again